[Musique]
nous sommes en 1979 pierre Avezard dit
petit Pierre vérifie les rouages de son
manège l'œuvre de toute une vie créée à
partir de matériaux que le simple garçon
vachait récupéré et assemblé
en 2022 la commune de Fay-aux-Loges où
il est vécu décide de lui rendre hommage
donc voilà la plaque que nous avons donc
posée fin 2022 donc en dénommant cette
rue la rue Pierre hazard
il a fait l'objet de moquerie terrible
alors dans dans la cour d'école le peu
de temps qu'il y a été c'est vrai que le
pauvre il avait un visage très déformé
voilà il entendait très mal il avait une
vue également qui était très difficile
et en même temps il a su exploiter voilà
toute cette richesse qu'il avait en lui
pour créer des choses magiques
il n'est pas allé à l'école ou si peu
mais son ingéniosité fait des merveilles
ces automates retrace des scènes de son
quotidien de son travail de garçon Vaché
évoque les innovations de l'époque un
aérotrin le Concorde le manège de Petit
Pierre faisait la joie des habitants
alentours
je me rappelle de dimanche où il y avait
je me rends pas compte 50 60 personnes
qui étaient là autour du Manège à
regarder un peu partout à se pencher
pour comprendre comment ça fonctionnait
c'était des vraiment des grands moments
donc je pense que beaucoup de gens qui
ont visité ça ont de très beaux
souvenirs pour le nouvel EHPAD c'est le
nom de Petit Pierre qui s'est
naturellement imposé
c'était un peu ce retour parce que on
s'est quand même moqué de lui pendant
des années des années et à travers
c'était un générosité cet arbre brut
qu'il a développé il a c'était un petit
peu sa revanche aussi
de la société de ce regard des gens sur
lui quoi morceaux de tôle piquet de bois
ne usagés sont limer martelés rabotés
pour devenir le merveilleux manège
en 1980 le documentaire d'Emmanuel clos
cesarisé fait accéder le manège de
petits pierres à la notoriété sa vie
inspire des pièces de théâtre jouer en
Europe au Mexique et même à Taïwan
Jean-François est un inconditionnel de
l'artiste autodidacte il a retrouvé un
enrouleur de fil de fer barbelés lui
ayant appartenu il s'était fabriqué une
machine qui lui permettait d'enrouler
voyez il mettait son fil de fer ici et
puis il tournait il enroulait et
l'enroulait le fil de fer et ensuite il
avait plus qu'à démonter ça cette partie
là pour récupérer son rouleau de fil de
fer en fait alors c'est typique de du
travail que faisait petit Pierre puisque
ce qui était important pour lui c'est
que ça marche que ça fasse le job comme
on dit le collectionneur et conférencier
militent pour une réhabilitation tout
azimute de bière Havard
moi j'essaye dans toutes les communes
environnantes voire même un peu plus
loin de faire en sorte que si on a un
stade un collège un lycée une salle
municipale une bibliothèque municipale
si on a quelques espaces à nommer
essayons de le nommer pierre
trois ans avant sa mort petit Pierre
autorisa le déménagement d'une partie de
son manège au musée de la fabulouserie
de d'ici dans l'Yonne où il est toujours
visible aujourd'hui
[Musique]